people of the internet retro Regan tour
here guys just a dad who loves games and
the stories they tell and I think this
video right here may have been one of
the most requested ones that I have seen
on this channel it's been a while since
we did our part one of Harry Potter and
the Order of the Phoenix but I kept
seeing people even months later say that
they wanted to see part two we've played
through a lot of the Harry Potter games
here on this channel and we made it all
the way up to order of the Phoenix
before Hogwart like he came out and now
we've had all this time and and I
haven't gotten around to doing it and
that's totally on me so here we are
today is the day people of the internet
part two Harry Potter in the Order of
the Phoenix I had to go back and look at
my last video to see where in the world
did we even leave off so the last thing
we did is we recruited I think we were
up to five members of The Da Harry I'll
see what I can find come on Harry you
must know something good you can teach
us I think I know just the SP
how about this one Harry oh new spell
time reducto right away new spell
reducto during the tri wizard tournament
let's go so yeah right here you need to
aim then move your
W reducto they talk a
lot they they interrupt all the time
rcto I mean they act like we don't have
a video to record here okay reducto all
right so we hold R2 to you know draw the
oneand and then it's just a
counterclockwise motion all
right
keep going okay me
again brilliant well done jinny blowing
things up comes naturally when you've
grown up with Fred and George very good
point let's see if anyone here is as
good as Jenny thanks for teaching that
to us
Harry he almost said that in a sarcastic
way let's see if anyone here is as good
as Jenny wait what did that say you have
five out of 28 da members recruited or
something like that
okay all right so we learned that now
what can I just like go
crazy apparently not come on hry
reducto I just I just can't get over man
the the animation like like the hand it
looks just like his hand in Chamber of
Secrets when lockart removes all the
arms braam
IMO productor was great I think the
others have some ideas about what we
could teach us next oh perfect all right
the others have some ideas Hermione my
Granda leaves you Harry oh thanks
Neville sorry I forgot what I wanted to
say wait wait I'm trying to talk to
Hermione Hermione let's look at the da
list and decide who to find
next where where's the da list Hermione
it's been like dude you don't even know
Hermione we had a memory charm cast upon
us we have no idea no idea me this is
harder than I thought your map and see
who's left to find map that's right okay
the map the Marauders map we do have
that in this uh this this school year
all right so we got the boat house it
says 0% discovered charms I'm not sure
why that one's kind of grayed out Clock
Tower 0% Clock Tower Courtyard Covered
Bridge defense against the dark man
looking at this really does make you
appreciate the Hogwarts Legacy layout
and the the map in that game and how
easy navigation is okay so great hall 0%
you know what Great Hall seems like a
good place to start let's just go
there hold on how do I get out of here
there we go okay now I think all we have
to do is follow the footprints on the
floor and oh yeah that's right hold X to
run so strange okay seventh
floor and then we still have have that
sort of strange bizarre Resident Evil
style camera where actually it's it's
like a sort of a fixed camera no it is
it's it's totally fixed I don't have any
the right stick just gives us one
waggling hairy that's all the right
stick does oh my goodness by the way
guys if you want to see more of this
series if you want to see me finish out
Order of the Phoenix all the way through
then don't forget to hit that Thumbs Up
Button hit that subscribe button that is
going to send us signal to both me to
let me know that you guys want more of
these videos and also to the YouTube
algorithm to say hey people like this
video let's get it out there to more
people and then I'll I'll know I'll just
be like oh wow look at all these likes
we definitely need to uh play through
this all the way through cuz I do enjoy
these man I mean it's definitely a
completely different style of gamepl
than what we're used to here in 2023
almost 2024 hard to
believe
all right so we're going to have to
navigate all the way
down into the Great
Hall oh going back up right there okay
hold on we lost we lost them we lost
them there they are keep it
up all right we're almost
there dude this this spot right here I'm
just reminded of that exact spot in
Hogwarts Legacy it is absolutely
incredible how far we've come all right
into the grade Hall we
go wait is this a cut scene or am I just
I just saw Hannah eott near the bottom
of the grand staircase I've never seen
anyone quite as nervous about their
exams Hannah Abbott bottom of the grand
uh Grand Staircase all right so do we
just head right back out hold on let me
look through here a little bit Nick I
just want to look through the Great Hall
so a little bit longer than the Great
Hall compared to Hogwarts like I see but
not quite as wide and then they have the
counters in here
instead I mean you can definitely see
though like where both of them had a lot
of uh the same ideas of course the
movies kind of gave us a picture of all
that you just screamed help what in the
world all right the physics in this game
were so strange whatever they actually
had a lot of good ideas I will say in
this one but just the controls right now
I don't even know if it translates as
well to the let's play for you guys like
when you're just watching it being
played but actually playing through this
they're just so so sluggish is probably
the best way I can think to say it is
this you
Hannah I don't know what she looks like
in the game maybe that's her bottom of
the grand staircase case though hi
Hannah yes it is I I I need to think to
remember oh I'm never going to finish my
revision well we can help you with one
subject we're having our first defense
against the dark arts meeting meeting at
am's band clubs she'll see us going
there I'll fail my owl's I'll be
expelled we'll all be expelled it's all
right we're going to use a secret
passage to get people to the meeting
really where is it we'll uh tell you
later
come on Harry not yet okay wait is that
it do we can you tell me where that
secret passage is shouldn't you be
revising charms Oh no you're right what
was it fqu said oh I'll never
remember okay we got her now what
portraits for that secret
passage oh that's right we have to talk
[Music]
to portraits in the area oh man this is
bad you guys this is bad
I do not remember okay so we found
her but now where is
that where is that leading us
to maybe we should just look on the
floor see if we get the footprints to
return well now we'll have to find a
secret passage to the seventh floor or
Hannah where come okay find one
somewhere on the grand staircase let's
look all right so if you just delay long
enough Ron and her mind will start to
answer it for you all right I'm just
going to I don't know go this
way how about you guys one of
you oh he moved for a second maybe we
just need to talk to him let's look at
the da list and decide who to find
next Ron just told me we need to find a
portrait we better check the portraits
for that secret
passage or the port trits as he says
there our br British fans is that how
you guys say say portrait do you say p
portrait P I don't think so I don't
think you guys pronounce the fully like
the trait do you it's like don't you say
it's it's more like portrait
portrit going somewhere I'm trying to
think if I've any ever heard anybody say
portrait
portrit okay who are you sir studious
success a healthy mind is an Inquisitor
M no this isn't where we're supposed to
go just going to keep
looking they said seventh floor so maybe
we have to go all the way up to the
seventh floor and find the portrait
there that's what I'm going with for
now although then when you talk to
Hermione she's like let's see who's wait
oh I do remember that one leads you
somewhere but okay floor
seven that's the fat
lady you don't want to go in there how
about
you
nope so what am I supposed to do just go
talk to other
portraits about this guy over
here
nope it is so strange not having camera
controls it's one of those things just
gotten so used to oh this guy I do
remember us talking to him
earlier earlier as in like months ago
when we last played this
game
wait who are you excuse me can I use
your shortcut please this might be it h
no you'll have to talk to me if you want
to use the shortcut you mean he'll have
to talk to me neither of you knows what
you're talking about can't I talk to all
of you you
could good if you could find where I am
then I could let you in I have to find
you
right okay we have to find that
guy on a different
floor how obscure is this
man okay so here's what I think we need
to do I think we need to go ahead and
set our path for another student hey can
we repairo this we'll
seeo okay that's kind of cool actually
do we get anything for it though birdie
bot beans oh yeah these little things I
forgot about these 150 to the next
upgrade no no idea what it even gives
you oh here's another one though that we
can
reparo right
here I'm pretty sure we need to go back
to the grand staircase and then go down
but I just want to see how many more of
these we can find
first that takes us up to oh wow still
have 130 to go okay that one's already
repaired and let's
see let's just go
back I think we head back down but
before we do that let's mark another
person
so have we done everything
in you know what let's let's kind of
start oh grand staircase shows
zero all these are gray out right now
though or is that just how it looks in
this maybe that's just how it looks all
right let's do this let's go up
to so we did Great Hall first right and
it still says 0%
discovered I think instead of doing that
we just go ahead and pop this out tasks
okay so Hannah is showing up in
red SE
snake Zachariah Smith helping with
homework okay so if you press on him it
shows helping with homework Hanah Abbot
it does doesn't say anything so that's
just showing us where she is though
right I'm going to do Zacharias looks
like he's out near the
greenhouse okay so hopefully on the way
to him we'll be able to find that
portrait and let me just get another
look at that guy one more time so it is
this dude right here so holding a book
and is that is that like a long long goe
he has
there I honestly can't tell all right
long kind of brownish red hair dark blue
clothing oh no this way
okay it is amazing when you compare this
to a game like Hogwarts Legacy which
just how much more there was to do in
that game I mean the the main quest of
this game game
guys would would literally be like a
side not even not even a side quest in a
lot of games these days I mean we're
it's a fetch Quest basically the whole
game is a
glorified fetch
Quest all right so we have to wait on
these that's another thing that kind of
breaks the flow of gameplay for sure is
when you have to stop and wait on these
okay it's not that guy I'm calling him
George Washington this dudee looks like
George Washington right
here that's what we're going to keep
calling him okay so that portrait right
there can we talk to that one
no oh hurry
down okay that's not him over
there all right so we got to
wait yeah see that's so for gameplay it
just completely breaks the flow oh wait
you want me to go in there no you want
me to wait right
here oh my gosh this one's taking a
while take time every day to
ride oh I don't know if I was supposed
to do that or not but I took off I
didn't want to have to
wait nope we
weren't we were not uh it's fine we
didn't waste any time it was going to
move anyway we would had to wait for it
to come
back is that
him I'm going to call him Horus he looks
kind of like Horus slug horn oh wait you
do want me to go in there studious
success you may pass Mr Potter Mr Potter
our new
celebrity oh great Zachariah Smith do we
have to tell him where the meeting is
yes we need to keep him in the da now
that he knows about
it all right
Zacharias how are you sir we've got a
meeting later no I've got too much work
to do and my schoolwork must come first
i' have thought you would have
understood that of course so if we help
you with your homework then you'll come
to the meeting what sh I suppose but
I've got to get a copy of the monster
book of monsters another fetch Quest
okay fine we'll get that for you let's
find the monster book of monsters it's
another fetch Quest you now have two
tasks Okay so we've got to do find the
portrait for Hannah oh check the
Marauders map to see which tasks you
have
started okay so anything highlighted in
Red so now like Hannah he is also
highlighted in red and his should should
say something about help him with
homework Find the monster book of
monsters okay so yeah that lightning
bolt all it marks is his
location which doesn't help us in this
case all right so let's see if we talk
to Hermione does she say something about
hey we need to recruit more people or
does she help me find the monster B we
need to find the book Zacharias needs
nice all right any ideas where it may be
hereone no not
you continue on sir trying to talk to
Hermione here nope nope I'm not going
anywhere until I've got a copy of the
monster book of monsters there's got to
be a way to like change who it's
highlighting
on how about you come on if you want me
to come oh my goodness fine all right
let's just walk away
from walk away from him
here okay Ron how about you come on
buddy nasty oh wait do you see it oh
wait I think I do I do see it okay maybe
maybe a depulso
my an AO it's probably going to attack
if we do
AO
Depo
AO come on
Harry
reducto repairo that's what he means
maybe we just walk up to it that's the
book Zacharias wants maybe I'm maybe I'm
making it harder than it needs let's do
it to
Zacharias dude Ron made it sound like it
was it was about to attack us and hey in
some Harry Potter games the monster book
has been a boss fight you got if you
know you
know it has been an actual boss fight
well his was super easy to find I wonder
if Hannah's is that close to the DA
meeting and we just made I'm still KNE
deep in work yes but you did say get me
some Wigan w
zaras and then I might be able to come
fine
zaras fine no shot dude where can I find
the daily profit try the Great Hall yes
yes the Great Hall owls everywhere there
they're bound to have one how can I get
the owls to give me a newspaper use your
head you're Harry Potter ain't
you there is so much going on in this
game right now and yet the organization
and keeping it
all is just bizarre it it is totally
bizarre see now let's see how it changed
so we still need to find a portrait for
Hannah Zacharias is he he can't even do
this apparently he just needs some Wigan
well potion all right so let's go back
through success I'm guessing Healy mind
is an inquis W potion is going to be
somewhere in the dungeons near the
potions
classroom but who the heck knows with
how this game is set up
the monster book was just right
there let's go all the way
down this is making me dizzy round and
round we go okay we're back in the
dungeon is she still just standing here
she is can you tell me where that secret
passage is shouldn't you be revising Oh
no you're right why can't we tell her
where it
is cuz we don't even know I think I
think that's why I think it's because
our character doesn't even know yet
excuse me do you know where there's a
secret passage from here to the seventh
floor yes of course I do I am guardian
of the great can you let us in my
password
is so it was super close to
her all right so do we tell him right
now scous
scoundrel all right I'm not going to use
it yet I'm just going to go see if we
can tell her
immediately and check that one off the
list just say scarus scoundrel to the
portrait of the astronomer on the
seventh floor you can use the passage to
get to the meeting that way no one will
see you getting there thanks Justin
Finch fletchley promised to help me with
my charms I'll tell him about the
meeting
too excellent 7 out of 28 da members in
the room of requirement wait because she
told Justin because we were at 5 that
just bumped us up all right now
Zacharias still needs Wigan well
potion that man pulled a fast one on us
he was like Hey I need the monster book
I can't go unless I get the monster book
we go and find the monster book and then
he's like
actually is there a secret passage
behind your portrait and what is that to
you boy you are not Slytherin so you
cannot pass unless you have the password
of course no I don't I thought not still
you could try asking some Slytherin
students I'm sure they'd be happy to
help
you I I don't know about that find the
all in the Mar's map just look for
anyone in the da and yeah I know that
Ron Hermione come on you got to give me
something here let's look at the da list
no we got to find
zacharias's
okay actually let's do the same thing we
did with Hannah it kind of worked out
right let's just start doing more than
one so Terry boot let's go after our boy
Terry that way at least if we've talked
to them all I don't know how many of
these you can actually trigger at
once then if we trigger all of them and
we just keep making our way through the
castle hopefully we won't have to do as
much
backtracking is right now it is pretty
much just us wandering this grand
staircase over and over and over
again what a good day dude set off on
another
adventure Hogwarts Legacy fans if you
know you know right studious success you
may pass Mr Potter all right we're back
in now hello looking for Terry boot my
friends no did that did they seriously
just hold
on what you led me right up to him Bal a
dash and
Pi he's annoyed I don't blame
him studious success he's like really a
healthy mind is an incred up
again all right did I just misread it I
think we supposed to go that way she
okay very clearly this
way not the
door oh wait wait wait I don't see any I
think they went in here didn't they
perfect
okay this game they really did have such
good ideas in terms of the layout of the
castle and everything but it's like they
forgot to actually build a mission
structure they forgot to build the main
part of the game so they're like oh crap
we've got all the students I'm missing
three cards that's all have you got them
we've got the students we've got the
layout but we don't have anything for
you to
do
Depo oh sweet sweet didn't know if it
would give us that or
not got more right there very nice okay
wait I just realized the footprints are
gone ooh what do you do AO
maybe hold on let's back up a little
bit come on Harry get that W to work man
reducto is not registering anything
right
now oh I bet you can totally do
something with that oh wait wait wait I
think I saw them go back
in yep there they
are okay now where where do you want me
to go hi this
way Quicken World potion I wonder what
Zacharias wants it for wait who cares
Hospital
Wing okay Hospital wing
all right well I thought potions but
Hospital wing also makes sense that
would have been the second place let's
tell
him let's tell him what hi Harry I heard
you found somewhere for the da to meet
what this is supposed to be secret it's
all right I heard it from Ernie who
heard it from Neville we'll see you
there then yeah how do I find the room
of come to the seventh floor and think
about how much you really need to find
the room and the door will appear uh
okay I don't know if Terry we're on our
way to Terry actually see
you you have two tasks to
complete I think we'll be all right so
Terry we need to tell Terry and then we
need to head to the hospital
Wing see this is what I'm saying man if
we just start going after the other ones
the other stuff just kind of naturally
Falls in a
place is this you there he is there he
is there he is Terry what's up
dude hello Harry I heard you found
someone for the da to meet does everyone
know about our secret meeting place uh
did you kill a basilic with the sword
from Dumbledore's office we're learning
how to use spells not swords oh okay I
don't know if Michael or anony knows
where to meet you better sell them see
you later yes all right now see at least
these guys are just like you know what
Harry I'm there got Zer whereas
Zacharias dude is like nah sorry I'm
going to need you to do something for me
first I don't know what we're supposed
to do with these things wingardium
Wingardium Leviosa oh put him in the
basket put them in the basket now how do
I drop X oh let's go that's actually
what you're supposed to do I was just
totally
guessing Okay that's sweat too and I
think I saw one over
[Music]
here drop you
in how many more you
need probably all of them right and then
it's going to give me 10 of those little
orbs 10 little orbs for all this work
oh okay maybe like 25 or something for
there why
we why the enchanted basket didn't want
the last one okay guess there was one
more why it didn't want those I have no
idea oh we got to keep
going you got to keep the wand movements
movements I don't know I know why I just
said it like that
movements got to keep the one movements
going you can't stop when you're halfway
through you got to you got to stick with
it all the way
through even once the animation triggers
it is not
complete there we go okay there
definitely looks like something is
supposed to go in the center right there
see do we need to repair one more yes we
do
is that going to give
us oh man is that is that the only thing
you can collect in this
game I know they have
uh they have those little mini games too
so all right so we're good
there I think we just need to go to the
hospital Wing now
right let's take a look I'm going to do
the same thing though instead of just
running straight up to the hospital Wing
let's go ahead and let's see who is
somebody that is close to where we're at
right now like Sprout she's not going to
be interested though is she okay the
ptil twins we can knock out two right
there let's do that
one all right so
they shouldn't be too far from here
wait you're not funny that's not
them right this way okay wait turn
around this where you want me to go it
is in the clock tower all right all
right
excuse me make way make
way do we do it hi would you like a go
exploding snap patience okay let's play
I think I was really bad at this oh wait
I don't think we did this one find the
matching pairs hurry up and find a match
we did do this one okay before the cards
explode okay select the card with the
left analog stick and then I guess
Square picks the card you need to beat
five okay all
right
okay oh
no oh my
goodness okay wait I I think I remember
you yes perfect all right does that slow
things down for a bit it does not oh
they just they just keep going they keep
going wait did I just see you yes we did
okay oh the lion the Lion's already
exploded we had the lion
earlier oh no I know I saw you
too giant squid wait where were you it
it's moving too
fast
no no we did really
bad
we I just started panicking okay wait
this one
a those don't
match best score five we only got
four let's try again though oh we scored
two it only counts
matches shees you have to be quick have
another go yeah yeah we're going to have
another go all right I can't let that
would you likeing snap doesn't like we
have to pay anything
so it is just for fun see can I also use
the d-pad that'd be much easier
actually nope you can't okay you and you
all right you and you all right you and
you all right not good there we
go I don't think we saw him
yet I think we did see
him
yes just in
time oh oh oh no where was she see like
once you get
one oh they just start moving so
fast oh I messed up again dude I just
start panicking
no okay
wait giant see giant Squid's already
gone
yeah I mean that's that's
it oh you can actually quit the mini
game I don't know why it doesn't just
end automatically as soon as you've lost
there's really no point okay one more
time one more time hi would you like a
go exploding SN patience okay let's play
Patience right patience
indeed hurry up and find a match before
the cards explode okay so
what is it on an actual timer or is it
based on how many I flip over that's
what I want to know so if I go
one and then let's do up here
two okay they immediately start I just
want to test this let me test this let
me see if these eventually go away I
think yeah they're definitely getting
faster they do
okay all right so then it pays to go
super
quick wrong
one so yeah I mean it doesn't even
matter oh
nice oh I think that was you
no oh I remember seeing her somewhere
yes
okay oh come
on oh we saw you earlier for sure come
on get him before he goes yes yes yes
yes
uh yeah we can't get any other matches
that was our best one by far though and
we kind of wasted the opportunity on the
first one cuz we were just letting them
explode what did we get three that time
oh a lot more than three four we got
four matches oh no we did score five
let's go so we matched it did we get
anything just for matching the best
score
what all right all right I know I more
would you like a go exploding snap
patience okay we weren't playing that
one legit at the beginning cuz we didn't
know this one this is it this is it
right
here okay I'm locked in I'm so locked in
right now what a start what a start what
a
start okay so dragon and that old man
looking guy he wait yes yes yes yes okay
we got giant squid right
here oh I think you were over here
weren't you no maybe right here yes come
on come on come on nice nice nice nice
giant squid giant
squid lion and oh wait the lady the lady
the green lady was here okay that's the
lion right there okay the old man's gone
we can't get him perfect oh we got it
this time we got it for
sure oh the lion the lion the lion the
lion he was over
here and then I think you were the green
one weren't you
boom Oh that's that's our best one by
far not even
close
yes let's go dude eight that
time all right I think with that one I
think I can walk away happily with the
new best score right
there have another go nope nope not
going to have another go all right had
to take a little break there and also
put on a sweatshirt because it's cold in
my office this time of year and whenever
I restart started the game we saved it
but it looks like it put me back in the
room of requirement so I think we said
we were going to go after the patil
twins anyway but we also still have this
task going with Michael corner and then
we still have the one with Zacharias
Smith as well so I'm just going to keep
those active and go ahead and go for the
ptil twins here let's see if we get the
little Footprints back yes there they
are all right let's go this way or yeah
see it just put us back on the seventh
floor even
though that's not where we were when I
saved
it but it's okay because it it did still
appear to save I think the last thing we
did was that exploding snap game
right you guys remember a lot easier
because it literally just happened on
stream or on the video rather okay let's
head down
here
[Music]
I'm a man of few
words yeah it's amazing how like tedious
this part of the game
becomes when you're just up down up down
up down up
down all right let's go this
way shortcut Dragon's egg pass friend to
[Music]
HFF all right into the Transfiguration
Courtyard here man I keep trying to use
the right stick to do camera
control it feels so bizarre not to have
camera control on the right stick I mean
even I I feel like this era of games
like PS3 era games were pretty widely
using the right stick for camera
controls at this point but I guess
because this one was tied to the Spells
they couldn't do
[Music]
that what's next I've lost my time
table there they are
nice come we need to get
to did you see him hey harry hi Padma
pavati uh uh can you make it to a DA
meeting later well we're supposed to be
meeting fresa trone she's going to
interpret a dream I had well can you
come after that I don't know meet that
divination and we can tell you then bye
bye so this is another one where we're
going to have have things to do they
don't just go automatically okay you
know have that about don't ask me pma's
been funny with me ever since the you
Bor she's still upset because you didn't
dance with her she's not said anything
oh Ron with girls it's what we don't say
that matters you WR a book translating
mad things girls do so boys can
understand
them all right check the Marauders map
to see which tasks you have started yeah
we already we know which tasks we've
started because so this one apparently
all you have to do is go to divination I
guess but we still need for Zacharias I
believe it was the Wigan weld potion
which is in the hospital wing and then
for Michael corner I do not remember
what we need for him at all so is there
a way that I can like does it give you
any other information like when they say
task okay so that way gives you location
what if I press up on the d-pad up or
down nothing so you get location here so
we could go ahead and let's say Hospital
wing all right so let's mark
that and then we'll go in that direction
which I guess one thing we could be
doing let's see if we can cast is it
incendio wonder if we can cast incendio
on these let's go to our spell list
here and let's see I think incendio was
side to side wasn't it left right left
right no up down up down okay all right
so let's go back
here nice there we
go some more of these uh mysterious orbs
here hey we we only need
15 I don't even know what you unlock
lock with this 10 for the next upgrade
all right maybe a what do you think
depulso no
AO okay I tried setting them on
fire AO is not
working Wingardium Leviosa Wingardium
Leviosa no way I did not think that
would work cuz we don't have defendo or
anything like
that your spells are now more powerful
there are more things to see in Harry
you must have been
busy all right and now we need 240 for
the next upgrade so we need to be on the
lookout for more little things like this
I guess that is kind of their design
philosophy let's see if we can do it on
these when you think
about come on up down up down oh we
actually can I guess that was what they
were when when they made this game they
wanted to put things in like that to try
and sort of break up
the monotony of just following these
footsteps the whole
time oh wait is that Michael I thought
we already he was already red on our
screen for some reason oh my goodness
Harry he almost fell off hi is it true
there's a DA meeting later try saying it
louder I don't think Maloy heard you
sorry can't wait for the meeting I don't
know if Terry or Anthony knows you'd
better tell them we've already told them
I'll tell jinia if I see her see you in
the room of requirement perfect okay
very nice so here here is done that's
Michael Corner Anthony Goldstein and
Terry boot crossed off our list did you
have to get so many people involved in
the da her we should be glad so many
people are prepared to do it although
Michael probably wouldn't have come
along if jinny wasn't going out with him
she's what she going out with since when
she got together with Michael at the end
of last year I don't like him big
surprise 10 of 28 da members in the room
of requirement very nice okay we're
making good progress and we're heading
to the hospital Wing we hope this will
be enough for Zacharias once we have
Wigan weld o and let's do this what was
it it was uh wingardium wasn't it oh
come on come on Harry waggle that wand
dude waggle it it's not working this
time the pulso it's just not like
letting me do spells at
all that's very strange try and
reposition a bit
here yeah it doesn't even look like this
is a something you can lock on
to all right well we tried we tried oh
hold on that picture though that picture
right
there when guardian leosa did we already
do this one I know we did some of the
pictures oh yeah he's he already done
he's he looks like he's already correct
is always happy I wonder what to secret
is oh wait now this one definitely looks
like yeah you can see how it kind of
highlights it a little
bit it's very
subtle which I mean I kind of like that
in terms of the visuals of everything
but it's also hard to see it's kind of
the same thing when you're talking to
characters as well oh now that's got to
be something
yeah all right so we're starting to get
a little better at spotting these
secrets press to
examine oh so that's good to know you
actually have to walk up to those it's
not enough just to unlock
it there's another one we can reparo
imaro raparo excuse me here
sorry raparo my American accent
here instead of
raparo what do you have to
say nothing you you you have nothing to
say all right Footprints where are they
going this
way okay that doesn't do
anything
oh great back to the
staircase here we are
again least we have some good music at
least right now when you guys see this
uh if if the music is muted at this
part you know why because it is
copyrighted music I'm guessing this
is this one probably is and
unfortunately they don't give you away
to turn it off in this
game okay how about you can
weo
nothing
[Music]
okay I may yeah I thought we saw one
right
[Music]
thereo how about you
yep another onei
Leos got a knight behind that
[Music]
curtain
hi continue
on ween World potion I wonder what
Zacharias wants it for oh wait this is
the guy this is the guy incendio
maybe
incendio excuse me have I found you you
have found us so if you want to see us
then walk through and remember the
password two heads are better than one
three heads why are you always leaving
me
up okay let's go ahead and use this you
think so wouldn't you but then I'm just
going to go right back okay so that puts
you up to the seventh
floor not any closer it seems to the
hosp three heads are better than one
that depends entirely on the heads so
let's go right back
through watch out Ron okay now they want
us to go this
way no no no no no no no no
no right let's look around for
zaras is that it right
there oh dude it looks like there's a
lot of things in this room we can do
incendio that's
it wait Did we get it I got it let's get
back to the library and give it to
Zachariah all right so I also noticed
when we walked by
this nice one Harry way hey that gives
you it's so Random the things that they
make for you to interact
with no we want this right
here can we do this side
too oh it also looks like we can un lock
on
to no
way
no I wanted to do the oh depulso will
actually okay got
that no no
no so I guess this one you can't
interact
with like what why
not
oh maybe I already did that one earlier
and didn't realize
it this one right here we haven't done
yet okay now I think oh no this one's
definitely not been done right here this
bed you can see the Blanket's not pushed
all the way to the top there we go had
to be lined up just
right
like you you can't even tell what
you're locked on to a lot of times wait
is it giving it to me repeatedly didn't
I already do
that no okay all right so if I hold
R2 all right all right it actually does
allow me to kind of flick between
targets here they probably taught us
taught us that when we played the game
for the first time months
ago they probably did teach us
that and I forgot about it okay so let's
the ptil twins they want to see us in
divination Zacharias okay let's mark
him and then let's head back to him
right now and see if we can knock that
one
out make our way to the fourth floor
here so I guess as you unlock more of
the portraits you're also
unlocking okay the footprints should be
able to detect when you have a a
shortcut that's been unlocked let's see
do we already yeah we got
that so they'll always point you in the
right direction at least I hope that's
how it
works oh did we do this
one no we did
not
all right already making our way only 55
more to go I guess now that I'm
actually looking out for it
instead knowing what to look for a
little bit more so what all do we have
that we can interact with we know about
the bricks those are the things that we
just or the stones I guess you would say
studious succcess you've got the beds in
the hospital Wing you've got the Torches
you've got the statues that you can
repair oh the rugs sometimes the rugs
like right here you can interact with
those go into the library try to be
certain portraits like this like that
one right there we we put
together and I'm sure there's some other
things that I don't have yet wait wasn't
Zacharias back
here that's not him though is it is this
him here I finished that homework ages
ago what I need now is to know when
nearly headless Nick died you lck
Gryffindor so I'm sure you can find out
and if we do you'll come to the meeting
yeah yeah I suppose
so this man this kid I should say oh
Harry are you looking for me oh he's
here that's even better could you tell
us when you died
don't you remember after all you did
attend my 500th death day party oh yeah
in our second year which means you died
in
1492 I knew that you would remember Miss
Granger for some reason my death day
seems to be quite a popular question at
the moment I do hope that means they're
thinking about another
party another
party okay Zacharias Sir Nicholas died
in literally standing right there yes
that's what I thought you mean you
already knew so the DA meeting is in a
room off the seventh floor Corridor you
just have to think about the to find the
room okay I'll see you
there Zacharias
man we know where this is going oh jeez
all right
so we' got both the ptil twins started
here let's see okay so right now we're
in the greenhouse or near the
greenhouse which is one that is close to
us I don't know why the teachers are
showing up on here wait why is Zacharias
back maybe it's something that we have
to go
into the room of requirement because it
said he wants to learn Rick the
simpra SU and Bones rescue from the
Slytherin Snape teacher mini Quest
Sprout teacher mini
Quest vzi and padas it's
still revealing the room oh let's do
Luna the thestrals let's see what that
one's
about well Zacharias was in the library
but I thought on the map it looked close
to
herbology
studious success you may pass Mr Potter
what a good day for learning another
day's education nope wrong
way there it goes it came back halfway
it was halfway
there
dude what did I miss oh in the
doorway
sheesh hopefully after a while I I'll
start to recognize where we're
at for anybody who happens to be new
watching this the regulars know this but
if you're new I'm terrible with
directions this is a real life thing I'm
terrible with it in my real
life thankfully I am married to a
wonderful woman who is
very Savvy when it comes to
directions but I myself am not and then
that carries over into video games as
well I'm constantly having to check MINI
maps and stuff although I did get pretty
good at Hogwarts Legacy I played so much
of that game though so that could be why
but hopefully after we play this a bit
more it's just something about how my
brain works I don't know what it is like
my brain thinks in like point A to point
B so like the whole time right now I'm
not even thinking about like spatially
where we're at all I'm thinking about is
following these Footprints to get to
where we need to
go okay so it would make sense since
they're thestrals that it's going to be
something
Outdoors what's going on back here
though
it doesn't look like
Luna
hi
Hi O that looks like something we could
interact with right there oh no it's
just a I think it's just meant to be a
bird
yeah like a
crow
hello oh wait what was that that one
definitely did something oh just for
walking up to it
okay that's a new one for
me what's going on here I think that's a
moly plant
excuse me is there is there a
significance to that maybe we're going
to need that later I think that's a moly
plant maybe somebody's going to ask us
for that later there's Ernie we got to
remember moly plant near Hagrid's
Hut oh we're just going to knock this
one out while we're here might as
well please Ernie just just hey Ernie we
found somewhere for the da to prti
I can't come just now I'm trying to get
snap's homework done have you completed
yours yet which one we have to procure
the ingredients for tomorrow's lesson oh
honestly Harry haven't you found them
yet and when am I supposed to do that
I've got all my other homework umb's
attentions and I'm teaching you defense
against the dark arts no need to be so
irritable listen you find five moly
plants on a mandre route and I'll find
the other potion ingredients for you
where am I supposed to find those things
well Professor Sprout has mandres in the
hery greenhouse and moly plants grow in
the castle grounds so we just have to
look for those does she know
everything oh no what's going on here
now okay that's one and then we already
know where a second one is you're going
to get those moly things Harry that's
one moly plant Harry now we need four
more so that's a moly plant seriously
nowhere that tracks it my potion last
lesson run I can't run right now either
for some reason better than gos he
burned a not letting me run there we go
had to finish that convers there were
moly plants around here yeah here it is
that's number two have you noticed CH
Chang's being funny around har turn
around great now we only need three more
plants one thing I will give them props
for making this game is the lack of
loading screens you do not have to deal
with a lot of loading look at that you
just walk up to the crow and see if it
does the same thing over
here yes it
does and yes it
does nice we're going to be getting
pretty close to
another there we go five more oh I saw
a you discovered a new animal footprint
what you've not visited our secret room
for a long time oh relax mytle you
should see what's in
relax your spells are now more powerful
all right so we still we're side tracked
from we came out here to find
Luna and the
thestrals every time I say luna my dog's
ears are like her name's Luna you guys
for those of you who didn't
know all right maybe we do have to have
a loading screen to go into the
forest why does that square keep popping
up I guess it's just to talk to
Ron she is deep here in the forest love
good staring
[Music]
at all right so we just have to remember
we still need three
more of the moly plants maybe there's
some out
here wait where'd she
go where what what the
heck we saw her in a cut scene but where
is she actually oh all the way down here
this game's kind of dark in some areas I
don't know if it's like like the Shadows
or what
but wonder if it looks thison have you
come could just be what this looks Luna
we found somewhere for our defense
against the dark recording software too
I can't come until the F has been fed
it's really shy though don't think it'll
come down until the big ones do okay
let's feed them we'll have to get the
food to the highest point in the
clearing okay so it's going to be
leosa Wingard
leosa all right we have to get them to
the highest point in the clearing so
that I guess that little area right
there and it's probably going to be this
thing huh wingardium
leosa all right oh no oh no I didn't
mean to let
go
need some
help there we
go okay so where is it right here you
can get the meat to the top I'm sure the
P will come down yeah this is it don't
roll out
no catch it
Harry all right we've got to lay it down
gently
here how's that L Luna is that good you
always get stuck when I try
of course hagra just oh wait maybe it
was showing me that this is like where
you can let it rest for a
second come on Harry come
on I wish you could walk while you're
casting
this no no no no no no no no no no no
come on yes yes yes yes
yes okay right here that looks like a
spot we can clear just wait till you see
the T
down close to the clearing oh it's it's
got to be this one right here
maybe look they're starting to come down
nice we must be able to smell the
blood are you going to be able to come
to the DA meeting then whatever you want
to do
whatever you want to doy do we really
need her help all right so that's 12 out
of 28 and
then the moly plants where else would
they be and then there's one thing we
needed to find it in herbology
Greenhouse which I guess it's
possible see if she Mark yeah okay so
she's gone she disappears Luna's
done let's mark hery and just head in
that direction
and as we go that way we'll look for the
moly
plants cuz they they should stand out
pretty clearly if they were here in the
forest cuz they have
those like white leaves on
there what is that for it's got to be
for talking to them we found lot of The
Da yeah that's what it was
for all right so you got the pumpkins
over there oh
ooh
Depo wait maybe we're supposed to water
that wiium
leosa hold
on I thought I saw something pop up
there for a
second dude the sound design on like the
pots and pans it really sound like it
sounds like something in my house right
now it's crazy okay so we don't get
anything else for triggering that
again all right what about you you do
anything okay it does light up on the
pumpkins AO you can do AIO you can do
depulso I don't know what we do just
pushed I thought I was trying incendio
oh it
broke I don't think hagard would be too
pleased with
that I still feel like there's something
we're supposed to do with those though
to get a little trigger one of the
little
upgrades wait maybe this way I know this
is not where the footprints are going
but maybe there's some moly plants in
here no no no kind of blocks it off all
right
did I see one in this area
nope I mean I feel like they should all
be kind of in this area since we found
two right
here but maybe the game is intentionally
spreading them out a bit all right let's
just head to herbology because we know
we need that
anyway there's also the task with
Professor Sprout that we could do there
oh wait wait wait I think I see one up
that
direction don't see any over
there yeah that's definitely one okay so
that's going to be three you're going to
get those moly things Harry we need two
more brilliant Harry we only need two
more I know Harry and I haven't taken
arithmancy like you m we can count to
five oh man all right I see him I see
them nice this one here plants we still
need one more though and right over
here you're going to get those moly
things Harry oh my gosh that's all those
moly plant things but we've still got to
get that Mandrake rout snake never gives
us easy homework does he we'll have to
go to the herbology green houses all
right that's where we marked herbology
green
houses so let's go ahead and go back
across the bridge
here can we go through there
oh my gosh the camera it's it's making
me dizzy right
now a stink
whatever
whatever I do love how you can at least
like let's see if I can talk to every
student I mean I wish they said more
than hi I'm going to get a job at the
ministry when I leave father's so well
connected it's a shame for those people
with lesser
parentage uh Slytherin
much how about
you okay fine
fine how about
you say Slytherin are the best go on say
it yikes no
sorry that is too funny oh dude look at
all these we didn't do any of these yet
a press to
examine see this is a like I actually
love finding all these little
discoveries like
this it's just the reward it it doesn't
feel these little bubbles just appear on
screen and hey after you collect a few
of them your spells are more
powerful
come on it's going to be Slytherin there
we
go which means we got a raven claw
behind this door right
here or this Stone panel whatever you
want to call
it all right wait did they actually use
the Raven they did they did not use the
eagle wait actually that that right
there kind of looks like I can't really
see the beak though nah it's definitely
a raven which is what they have above
too okay so back to herbology that's
where we need to
go I assume you're going to need those
those more powerful Spells at some point
will be beneficial possibly
maybe cuz right now we haven't had to do
much battling at all
yet straight no through the portrait
okay flaming earwigs ah they're
everywhere hi Harry okay this
way oh hold on there's a bunch of these
in
here really okay wingardium is not
working
no incendio depulso depulso does work
but wiard leosa that's interest okay so
it worked on that one maybe I
just did I not press it just right on
this
one that is so strange maybe it only
works when there's something behind
it
try this one right
here nope no luck all right moving
on waiting for the footprints okay back
down
sorry wait where did we mess
up Professor um will sort him out where
did we mess
up
oh I guess we just completely went the
wrong way right when we got out of the
portrait yes here we go all right Mand
Drake root Professor Sprout do we talk
to you or do we just go look for
it this looks like the Mimis
meltonia that's the mandre there
nice all right so
do I have to do AO or can I just pick it
up I wonder if we actually need to
things are actually put on the ear muffs
first we'll need ear muffs Harry there
will be some in the greenhous somewhere
I'm ahead of you got you
herion that's kind of cool actually
changes up the sound when you put them
on can take now what no we can't what we
can take these off now
no need to
shout better get this lock back to you
took them off after wait what Remy you
took them off after we pulled the manand
Drake out I'm so
confused all right so now it's back to
who was it it was somebody down
by Ernie there we
go and I don't think there's fast travel
in this game either H me next I could be
totally wrong flaming ears I guess their
idea of fast travel is more of just
using the
portraits but so far the traveling
around has been the main purpose of the
game that has been our primary
goal maybe once we unlock the da like
get all the members must be so upet but
I have so like my memories of this game
are so cloudy and I don't know
why because I played
it maybe I just got burnt out and never
finished it I definitely played it but I
can't I can't remember like what happens
like the game play from here on
out get lost that's that's very possible
it means it's just more of the
same all the way
through okay
Harry all right Ernie where you at dude
you still down there all the way by
Hagrid's Hut can anyone remember the
other
[Music]
ingredients there he
is is kind of peace F being out here we
got them five moly plants and some
mandre rout tremendous if you leave them
with me I'll get them ready for the
lesson great see you in the room of
requirement for the DA
meeting boom all right 13 out of 28 da
members in the room of requirement we
just need one more to get to the halfway
point which the twins I guess they're
still just
waiting a divination with trani all
right let's see who let's find at least
one more okay there's Sprout but I don't
think she's going to give us
one find uh Fred George and Lee Jordan
wow that's three of them right there but
something tells me that that's going to
be more than just
one okay that one says finding the
Gargoyles for Colin getting back the
camera Cho is Mischief in the allery
Angelina Trophy Room
trap Zacharias now w waiting to learn
Rick to SRA all right let's go for for
Cho in the allery
here we're already outside so hopefully
it won't take us too long to get to the
allery would be great if we could just
hop on a
broom and fly over
there the limitations I guess of this
generation of
gaming although they probably could have
done it this is PS3 this this one wasn't
that long ago yeah the allery should
just be right over here there's Hogwarts
right over here but like I can't like if
you guys are wondering why I'm not
giving you a better shot I can't control
the camera at all the camera is
completely controlled by the game itself
and by the position of my characters
like maybe if I back up
here which to be honest like it doesn't
do a terrible job a lot of times when
you have a game that doesn't give you
any control of the camera camera it's
it's really rough and I mean I would
still absolutely prefer to be able to
control the camera but all things
considered it doesn't do a terrible
job as soon as I try to start moving the
camera you'll just if if you see Harry
just like just randomly doing that
without me casting a spell you know I'm
still trying to move the camera
around oh do we lose the footprints n
they're still
going all the way up to the allery
here hopefully this is just a very quick
one
hey I really appreciate the sound like
just the the wind and the birds that you
can hear
there all right anything we can do with
this statue there's a good shot of
Hogwarts right
there there's a good
shot and I believe this was the best
looking version of the game so we're
playing on the PS3 which when I played
it back in the day I played on the Wii
which was a lower resolution of
course much less power on that
system and I think I think we should
stay outside in case filch turns up fil
is in the dungeons I know the first
brought puking pastels and covered the
place in ow outside Ron what was that
for oh Ron
honestly
Ron
okay let's see if we're supposed to do
anything in here but yeah I was saying I
can't remember if this one uh I'm sure
there was a PC version but I think it
was pretty much on par with oh hi Harry
what we have here how are you fine has
Gryffindor got a new keeper yet yeah
it's my friend Ron Weasley the tornadoes
hater yeah you sending a package yes a
present from my mom's birthday but I
forgot to put the address PR on it and
now the owl's flowing up there and won't
come down I'll get it for
you uh okay the owl's flowing up there
and won't come down so do we have to
just excuse me Cho I need to get excuse
me excuse
me she's not letting me bu funny oh
cuz maybe we're just supposed to use our
wand
uh oh my thank you Cho
goodness
oh wait hold on do we have to do a
little okay push right there we
go he's going to move again you already
know the owl's totally going to move
again come
here oh
almost thanks for helping me
Harry I really appreciate be
careful thanks for
helping she just keeps saying thanks for
[Music]
helping oh man just like the like the
actual gam play like this is so rough no
I've got to all the way
back no
way it's just like it's it's so
confusing too because they're playing
like this jovial music right
now and then we're
[Music]
just take
your I will I will Cho I will I'll take
my
time my goodness you got to be kidding
me
[Music]
there's my real life Luna I don't if you
guys heard her whining right there she
probably wants out oh there it is all
right I guess oh keep going he's going
to go all the way to the top isn't
he perrow maybe
yeah okay now see like that that's kind
of
cool it needs to be more like that and
then something to cut down on just good
job hag not watching oh my gosh of
course okay let's go let's go back this
way
now if he just goes right back to that
same spot I'm going to lose it least he
goes up okay all right all right we
we've got to be getting
close
hey oh you should have just grabbed it
right
there we'll have to find a way to climb
up to
him let's see this looks like something
we
can
repair you are near something you can
climb
this we didn't learn about this in care
of magical
creatures the music right now sounds
like we should be like flying on a Thal
together across the the high the
surrounding
Highlands instead it's
Harry making his way through the allery
trying to catch this ow thank you Harry
that was really nice of you we got it
finally no problem I like spending time
with you Harry yeah thanks I mean me too
oh here we go here we go here we go I
was wondering if uh yes I mean would you
like to uh to bring Marietta to the
meeting as well it's in the room of
requirement oh yes all right then
great I'll see you later then yeah of
course how did it go how did what go oh
nothing sometimes you make no sense at
all mining that's because you have the
emotional range of a teaspoon Ronald
makes me think about the one go one go
ball with me if you remember that line
from Goa of fire he just he just runs
all the words together too funny all
right guys now that we are halfway there
in terms of all the da members I think
that's going to be a great place to end
this video if you made it here all the
way to the end go ahead and leave a
comment below with the wand Emoji the
wand emoji that will let me know that
you made it all the way here to the end
of the video and I can't wait to chat
with you guys again when part three
comes along because you know we got to
see this dud to the end hope you all
have a fantastic rest of your day as
always thank you all so much for
watching and I'll talk to you again
soon